Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
the sixth chapter, the chapter of
authored by
we heard yesterday
the statement of the prophet
very powerful statement.
He said the best
of them speaking about the tribes of the
Arabs and the tribes of the Arabs are
precious metals. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam said in
the narration of
also in
he said
[Silence]
he said people
are precious metals.
The best of them in Jahyah
are still the best of them after the
coming of Islam as long as they have
knowledge and knowledge here being
referred to as understanding
right it's not just facts it is true
understanding and insight of the book of
Allah of the sunnah of the prophet Sam.
And so
there is
no way that a person can reach the
heights of virtue without knowledge. No
matter how good their intention is. As a
matter of fact, the idea that one's
intention
can be very very good without knowledge
is also incorrect
because intention has details to it.
Intention needs understanding and
knowledge in order to purify it in order
that a person may
perfect his intention. And
so all of these things need knowledge.
There's no way to climb
the rungs
of the ladder of emen without knowledge.
It is not possible. It's just you do not
have the technology that you need in
order to
obtain that highness. No matter how much
a person wants something, no matter
how good their intention may be, no
matter how strongly they desire it, if
they don't have the means to do it, they
will not be able to do it. And so
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
places this as a condition.
We see the next narration here. The
narration
which is number 70 in the order of
the narrations of the book and it is the
second narration in this chapter.
Chapter number six
says
do we know what
what his name is? Who knows his name?
No,
mentioned it before.
[Silence]
and listen to this statement. Memorize
it. Memorize it and think about it all
the time. As a matter of fact,
place this narration
on
the forefront of your mind. And whenever
you look to do something or say
something or make a decision, remember
this statement.
[Silence]
He says
indeed the
life of this duny this world
is sweet
and green.
It's very
alluring. It's very seductive.
At first taste, it's very sweet. At
first glance, it's very green.
And indeed, Allah has placed you here in
this dunya in order to watch what you
do. and to observe your decisions and
choices
and so
shield yourselves from the
misguidance or the mischief of the dunya
and specifically the seduction of women.
Here he's saying shield yourselves
the same wording we said it we said it
is what
using a shield shielding yourself
shielding yourself how do we shield
ourselves by
observing Allah's
commandments and abstaining from his
prohibitions. So he's saying so shield
yourselves from the seduction of the
dunya and the seduction of women
specifically are women and the seduction
of women not
the
you know a part of the seduction of the
general seduction of the dunya.
Yeah, it's the same thing, right?
So, it's it's all part of the same
thing, but but here he's pointing out
this specifically
because of its danger. it
a very
specific and potent danger on its own
all on its own and that is the seduction
of women. So here he's saying from the
seduction of the dunya and the seduction
of women. The seduction of women is part
of the seduction of the dunya, but it is
so potent, so dangerous, so deadly that
it warrants its own mention.
He says,
"So protect yourselves from the
seduction of the dunya and specifically
the seduction of women.
For indeed, the first
fitna
that Bi is
led astray with was that of women and
had to do with the seduction of women.
And so these
this here is our prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam warning us from stepping
off of the path. And one of the things
that will take a person off of the path
most thoroughly and most swiftly is the
seduction of the dunya in general,
specifically the seduction of women. And
the seduction of women
is not just speaking about
that of Zena. He could have said Zena
and but it's more broad than that. It's
not just the seduction of Zena, but it's
also the seduction of,
you know, anything that has to do with a
romantic love which causes a person to
sacrifice their hereafter for. This is
what is intended,
right? If a person is not blessed with a
good wife for instance, a wife that
fears Allah, a wife that doesn't drive
him to evil, a person could have his
fortune befall him with a woman that is
incredibly seductive to him and only
pulls him to evil. this person, even
though she may be his wife, her
obedience may take him off the path as
well because romantic
love or romantic
interest is incredibly potent to the
point that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said he he described
it as
that there is no seduction more powerful
than the seduction
of
a woman with respect to
blinding a man, making a man almost
seemingly lose his mind even if he is a
very intelligent person. And this is not
necessarily a bad thing. It is a bad
thing when it is used for bad.
And so we see a good woman
will have a very good effect on her
husband.
A companion
her
dowy. This is Anna Malik's mother. her
dowy,
her m
was that Abu Tala accept Islam,
right? And so her dowy was that Abu Tala
accept Islam. And so because of a good
woman and she used her seduction
to
introduce him to the best of the life of
this world, companionship of the prophet
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam and the
best of the hereafter.
However, that can be the opposite as
well.
There were people during the time of the
companions the
who completely left Islam left the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
u
companionship because they fell in with
the wrong woman. And this is something
that I'm sure all of us have stories
about. So sometimes it's oh is it
only women? No, no. Men are very
powerful in their own right. Women are
extremely powerful in their own right. A
man may conquer the world and then a
woman may conquer a man. Right? And so
this is very potent. Seduction of a
woman is incredibly potent. So the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
points it out and that it is a warning
for men and it is a warning for women as
well to not use this tool or not use
this ability for bad or evil.
Sai.